Speaker 1: Let's hear from a couple of
other people. Just remember that putting
parentheses in front of your nickname
on Discord to get to the top of the list
guarantees you will not speak to me because
that it's just it's just a trick. Okay?
People are like, oh, it's alphabetical. I'll start
with parentheses and then I'll be at the top.
I don't even look at those. So that's a good
way to to not get on. Let's go to Chris from
Massachusetts. Chris, welcome.
Speaker 3: Hey, David. Hello.
I don't have much for you today, I guess.
Have you have any other callers
talked about the Roe v Wade decision?
Speaker 1: Only all of them.
Speaker 3: Only all of
them. What about the the leak?
Speaker 1: Yeah, well, I mean, listen, the leak,
some are saying, is the most
serious thing that's ever happened,
worse than the Trump riots,
the fact that this leaked
three weeks early. It's like Pearl Harbor.
Speaker 3: Yeah. I mean, that, in my opinion,
is probably one of like, I don't know the lesser
or consequential factors of this whole kind of I
agree thing that's unfolding. It is a kind
of one thing though is I've heard people.
Saying a line that, you know, oh, the leaker is
this patriot and we don't really know why this
content was leaked. I agree. So I would I would be
hesitant to, you know, kind of like take that line
so early because, you know, there's a compelling
something that I find compelling is the idea that,
you know, this was leaked earlier than the
normal Supreme Court summer publishing of
these decisions. Yeah. And get it into the media
cycle. Earlier than it would be in farther away
from the midterms. So they can run through the
media cycle and maybe folks will forget about it
before the midterms happen.
Speaker 1: It's very speculative.
It's very. I mean, listen, you could say, oh,
no, they leaked it the day that the primaries
started to have the maximum effect. Or you could
say what you're saying, which is if you wait,
it has more of an effect. So by leaking it,
instead of waiting until the end of June
now, voters can have it in mind for
all of the primaries in May and June.
I think you can make the argument either way. We
just don't know. For me, it's like we found out
three weeks earlier. That's that said, it's
really not a big part of the story for me.
Speaker 3: Do you think there's any merit in
like the idea that, you know, these leaks,
you know, if they were to happen again
in the future, would influence, you know,
the Supreme Court justices in their decisions?
Speaker 1: I, I really don't because I mean,
I don't know. They're appointed for
life and they have great security.
It's just hard for me to imagine that.
Speaker 3: Yeah. Because it seems like
because of the fact they were appointed for
life. I mean, how much is public opinion,
right. Really influence their decisions?
Speaker 1: I agree completely. Yeah,
I just. I just don't see it.
Speaker 3:
All right. Thanks, David.
Speaker 1: All right. My
pleasure. There's Chris from Massachusetts
with some relevant elements for today's show